buonasera qualche giorno fa dopo il
lavoro e dopo aver ritirato i miei figli
a scuola mi trovavo come mi capita
spesso a una festicciola pomeridiana di
bambini di 5 6 anni quando un po stanca
per la routine quotidiana o più stato
una sedia libera nei pressi del buffet e
ho pensato di appoggiarmi un minuto non
di più perché queste situazioni non lo
concedono e non aveva nemmeno sfiorato
il sedile quando una bambina che mi
arrivava più o meno qua mi si è
avvicinata brandendo una spada laser e
intimandomi di lasciarle il posto perché
era suo
io ho per un po per istinto
incondizionato mi sono effettivamente
alzata di scatto per lasciarle il posto
anche perché temevo ci potessero essere
i genitori della piccola tiranna
acquattati da qualche parte e devo
confessare che per un attimo ho sognato
di sentire pronunciare una frase che non
sento pronunciare dai tempi di mia nonna
c'è qualcosa tipo porta rispetto alla
signora ma poi chiaramente mi sono
guardato il rettore non è possibile
questa bambina pensi che io sia una
signora anche perché tra noi mamme ci
trattiamo con un tale un modo così
informale e la moda del giovanilismo è è
così diffusa che persino i bambini ci
vedono come dei loro coetanei e speravo
che magari almeno qualcuno le dicesse
dai non fare l'antipatica matilde ma non
è andata nemmeno così la bambina ha
ricevuto un plauso generale con una
reazione tipo a ma come come si fa
rispettare questa bambina sicuramente un
futuro mentre io ero sotto lo schiaffo
sotto la minaccia della sua spada laser
e da questa da questo episodio è partita
tutta una mia riflessione e ho iniziato
a fare casa tante piccole
cose di tutti i giorni ad esempio ormai
quando salgo sul tram con i bambini noto
che la folla si apre come il mar rosso
per far sedere i bambini no mentre una
volta si faceva sedere la vecchina
allora ora non so la vecchina è ormai la
zitella gattara leghista che doveva fare
la spesa online starsene a casa invece
dei facili sgambetti col bastone col suo
malefico carrello scassato mentre i
bambini con la loro spontaneità con la
loro coloro modo di fare contagioso sono
diventati un po i protagonisti come si
vede in queste le sull'illustrazione di
maurice sendak degli anni sessanta e
sono quelli che comandano in tante
situazioni
il nostro il nostro agire quotidiano
e mi è tornata alla mente una frase di
mia madre che poco tempo prima mi aveva
detto sono proprio sfortunata perché
sono nata quando i bambini dovevano
tacere è portare rispetto agli anziani e
sono anziana quando i bambini e mettono
i piedi in testa ai vecchi
io naturalmente non ho concordato sul
momento perché l'ho presa come una spesa
diretta la maleducazione dei suoi nipoti
e quindi dei miei figli però
ripensandoci devo dire che forse non
aveva tutti i torti
allora iniziato andare dove questa foto
di piccoli tiranni e ho iniziato ad
andare indietro nel tempo e ho pensato
alla storia del cinema mi è capitato di
rivedere di recente questo musical tutti
insieme appassionatamente dove il papa
siamo in austria negli anni trenta il
papa un fischietto e ogni ogni bambino
corrisponde un suono diverso del fischio
lui li chiama e loro si presentano con
un saluto militare e poi si mettono
sull'attenti invece nel made man che è
una produzione dei giorni nostri ma su
una serie televisiva che però racconta
dall'america degli anni 50 i bambini in
questo caso i figli del protagonista don
draper fanno veramente stringere il
cuore quando si guarda questa sull meno
a noi gente di oggi abituati a trattare
i bambini come se con rispetto con cui
li trattiamo oggi questi bambini non
vengono assolutamente messi a parte di
nessuna decisione di nessun problema
all'interno della famiglia vengono
mandati a letto con praticamente
sfolgora t con lo sguardo e devono già
capire che devono abbandonare la tavola
anche se non hanno finito di mangiare e
chiudersi in camera perché i genitori
devono bere un cocktail parlare o fumare
o invitare amici a cena e la loro unica
compagna di giochi con pa e la
televisione e ho pensato poi gli esempi
che mi venivano in mente della
letteratura e mi ha saltato agli occhi
questo libro di fine ottocento del
tedesco ai di kaufman pierino porcospino
praticamente un libro ancora edito in
italia è una sera una serie di rime che
presentano delle minacce veramente
macabre fino alla morte violenta
dedicate verso i bambini che infrangono
norme anche semplici come appunto non
tagliarsi le unghie come il caso di
questo pierino e qui c'è il confronto
tra
vedete dalla parte alla vostra sinistra
e alcune immagini del libro del classico
dell'ottocento con bambini che fanno
delle fini orribili e dall'altra parte
invece un libro uscito in questi anni in
cui la situazione completamente
capovolta c'è un bambino che educa deve
viene invitato a educare il suo papà è
vero che è soltanto uno stratagemma per
far capire al bambino le norme del
vivere civile però allo stesso tempo
eloquente come in un caso ci sia il
genitore che imputa le mani del bambino
con una tenaglia nel libro di fine
ottocento mentre ora il bambino prende
in giro il papa che piange
accompagnandolo a scuola mi sono chiesta
quindi che cosa è successo in tutto in
tutto questo tempo e che cosa in
particolare mi sono interrogata sono i
genitori nati negli anni 80 sui miei
coetanei essendo io un genitore aveva un
osservatorio privilegiato su tutti i tic
e le manie dei genitori i miei coetanei
e non mi so provato a darmi delle
risposte
noi genitori nati negli anni 80 siamo
figli sicuramente di persone che hanno
vissuto sia il boom economico che 68
in un caso o nell'altro credendo noi
nella psicanalisi che sito a tutti i
traumi nell'infanzia
pensiamo che i nostri genitori abbiano
sbagliato qualcosa con noi quindi o sono
stati troppo di destra troppo consumisti
perché ha comunque sono vissuti nel boom
economico oppure sono stati troppo e
troppo di sinistra troppo comunisti
troppo libertari perché hanno fatto il
68 è sicuramente
se hanno divorziato hanno fatto male a
divorziare se non hanno divorziato
avrebbero dovuto divorziare in ogni caso
noi vogliamo essere migliori di loro e
crediamo di poterlo fare
differenziandoci attraverso dei
comportamenti alternativi che vado a a
esplorare cosa succede noi genitori
siamo anche molto abbiamo paura perché
siamo noi abbiamo fatto dei figli in un
momento di crisi economica rispetto ai
nostri genitori che invece li hanno
fatti in un momento di crescita e i
nostri stessi genitori con patendo c
aiutandoci ci permettono ci danno
l'autoindulgenza per drammatizzare la
nostra condizione che in realtà è una
delle condizioni penso ha praticamente
la più comune dell'umanità che ora
invece viene vissuta appunto in maniera
drammatica siamo anche persone che
famose per non avere voglia di crescere
e forse perché giustificati perché siamo
stati a lungo nel precariato e quindi
siamo stati abbiamo avuto insomma una
giustificazione a voler rimanere sempre
piccoli tra virgolette è sicuramente un
sintomo di questa cosa e che abbiamo gli
stessi consumi culturali dei nostri
figli perché guardiamo con loro i
cartoni della pixar leggiamo il libro di
hunger games andiamo al concerto di
jovanotti coi nostri figli
tutto questo fa di noi dei genitori
paurosi che si aggrappano a qualsiasi a
qualsiasi moda qualsiasi tende a
qualsiasi tendenza pur di trovare delle
soluzioni delle risposte a questa
condizione che ci fa paura e
naturalmente il mercato ha una risposta
ad ogni nostra paura in un prodotto
questo è il par ed in parenti nng
dovrebbe significare semplicemente
essere genitori invece
diventato ormai un settore vero e
proprio del commercio che ci
targettizzati inserisce nelle mailing
list e prova a venderci una serie di
prodotti tra i più futili del mondo ed è
anche una disciplina perché una
disciplina che si può studiare nei libri
si può andare a studiare anche nelle
associazioni e si può imparare da dei
consulenti specifici e anche delle vere
e proprie materie anche un po indecenti
tipo allattamento al seno ginnastica del
perineo noi non ci facciamo mancare
niente ci scriviamo tutto perché
pensiamo che questo faccia di noi dei
genitori consapevoli e progressisti e la
consapevolezza è il concetto del grande
concetto che fai un po la mo di tutte
queste questi nostri comportamenti
perché pur di rappresentarci come
virtuosi noi siamo disposti a comprare
qualsiasi cosa in questo senso siamo
anche vittima vittime del pensiero
politicamente corretto che è molto di
moda e di conseguenza vogliamo
rappresentarci come persone buone e
giuste soprattutto sui social e quindi
vogliamo essere visibili sui social come
persone che fanno tutte le scelte giuste
anche per i loro figli per cui postiamo
la foto non di nostro figlio che si
distrugge di tv 9 ore al giorno ma del
suo primo vaso fatto al tornio oppure
dei pannolini lavabili che da stendere
fuori dal dal balcone e allora questa
immagine rappresenta l'adula che è
un'altra una di queste mode che vorrei
raccontarvi la dura eh
una nuova figura che va molto di moda
tra le neo mamme ed è una figura presa
dalla cultura filippina è una figura che
accompagna la donna nel periodo
perinatale allora questa pubblicità dice
evil woman the service adula io non ne
sono così sicura
diciamo che le nostre nonne non
sentivano il bisogno di uno spazio dove
andare a lamentare di un'associazione
dove andare a parlare con le altre mamme
o a lamentarsi con l'adula delle
smagliature
l'unico spazio di cui avevano bisogno
semmai era il rifugio anti bombe anche
se erano incinte e qui tutta una serie
di prodotti che fanno di noi persone
migliori e che noi non esitiamo a
comprare c'è il pannolino di mais quindi
biodegradabile c'è il vello d'aniello
che si sistema nella carrozzina perché
il bambino non su di non abbia calda non
abbia freddo stia sempre la temperatura
giusta l'amaca di vino che invece presa
dalla tradizione degli eschimesi per cui
il bambino impara addormentarsi da solo
oscillando il libro in fibre in fibre
naturali
naturalmente anallergico i passeggini
alti perché il bambino non deve prendere
lo smog dei tubi di scarico dei suv di
altre mamme probabilmente nei suk e il
passeggino per fare fitness perché la
mamma possa fare fitness
c'è poi la fascia la luna belli che
questa fascia che trasmette musica al
feto nelle vibrazioni e adatte a liquido
amniotico e c'è anche una fascia che
permette al papa di sentire i calci del
bambino una cosa di cui l'umanità non
aveva mai sentito bisogno però noi
abbiamo anche questo c'è poi una scuola
la scuola del portare e che ha proprio
un posto che insegna come fasciare il
bambino
alla maniera africana che una cosa
sicuramente bellissima l'ho fatto
anch'io però ormai abbiamo queste mamme
che si riducono a lavorare il combal
computer otto ore al giorno quel bambino
legato nella fascia e non contenta di
aver sudato tutto il giorno col bambino
addosso c'è la prolunga per il letto
matrimoniale perché adesso il bambino
deve fare con sleeping quindi deve
dormire accanto ai genitori e perciò c'è
insomma l'arredamento per l'infanzia
prodotto questa questa novità così la
mamma può goderselo sempre appiccicato
al corpo anche di notte
c'è poi lo sciroppo alla bava di lumaca
che naturalmente ci ha convinti subito
perché è omeopatico e non sovvenzionare
terribili case farmaceutiche quindi fa
sembra fare schifo ma in realtà è una
cosa bellissima e lo spazio del per la
poppata libera nei musei e nelle fiere
perché naturalmente a una settimana dal
parto noi vogliamo fare le svedesi della
situazione andare a vedere la mostra al
museo e poi quella che vedete qui è la
grotta del sale un posto pieno di sale
che serve a far sgocciolare il naso del
bambino proprio come succederebbe al
mare però costa molto più della casa al
mare
l'abbonamento a questo post per le
allergie te c'è il test kinesiologico
quindi un test non invasivo le mamme
ormai sperano un po che il figlio sia
allergico al glutine perché questo nuovo
grande nemico comune e quindi bisogna
fare il test antiallergico ma per non
fare quello tradizionale invasivo con le
lamette si può semplicemente appoggiare
sul muscolo l'allergene
e il muscolo che secondo la medicina
cinese conserva tutta la memoria della
storia del corpo risponderà e dirà al
chinesiologo se il nostro bambino è
allergico a qualcosa le mamme che vanno
dal chinesiologo dall omeopata
naturalmente non fanno il corso pre
parto ma lo yoga in gravidanza e
imparano anche il canto tantrico che è
un canto che si può fare durante il
parto e per una sorta di gorgheggio che
poi uno non riesce mai a fare poi quando
partorisce ma se riesci sicuramente lo
staff medico lo odierà al punto da non
somministrargli l'epidurale perché con
questo non voglio associare volevo farvi
sorridere dei nostri tic delle nostre
mani e o se non siete genitori delle
mani e che sicuramente avete riscontrato
nei vostri amici che compulsivamente
postano foto dei loro figli su sui
social e non voglio dire che dobbiamo
rinunciare a tutti quelli che in realtà
vi ho fatto vedere che sono sicuramente
dei progressi delle conquiste che
abbiamo fatto
la mia riflessione solo che molto spesso
per differenziarci dai nostri genitori
in maniera virtuosa abbracciamo anche
delle pure mode che non hanno nessun
fondamento scientifico
perciò questo è aderire in maniera
entusiastica a tante pseudoscienze del
bene che ci fanno apparire buoni
qualche volta non funziona perché
moltiplica le fonti di sapere in maniera
confusa ma soprattutto tende a formare
dei bambini ultra coccolati che non sono
in grado di affrontare
niente senza tutto il kit per la vita di
cui noi li riforniamo e che non sono
capaci nemmeno di passare un'ora se non
sono impegnati nel laboratorio di cucito
nel workshop di cucina le mode della
puericultura peraltro cambiano molto
velocemente come la moda scarpe per cui
se hai un figlio nato nel 2005 che hanno
detto che devi farlo dormire in camera
sua
se è nato nel 2007 noi invece deve
dormire accanto a te perciò noi dovremmo
avere la saggezza di informarci
naturalmente su tutto senza però derivi
completamente ma lasciando spazio al
nostro senso critico e al nostro istinto
che sotto palate di sensi di colpa e
apprensione sopravvive persino in noi
genitori nati negli anni 80 la
conclusione quale non dovete andare a
casa e gettare i pannolini di mais nei
pre dare uno schiaffo a vostro figlio
perché fosse un giorno non ha fatto
sedere una signora sull'autobus ma
ricordare che il parent in in questa sua
versione commercializzata e narrativi
data può sembrare uno sport molto più
estremo del del semplice e universale
naturale essere genitori grazie